This movie exists
Child actor looks nothing like his older counterpart
Unsettling scalp-sniffing fetish
Promotes stalking
Scene does not include lapdance.
High school student has Rear Window poster…
yeah right.
Uncle Ben picks up a perfectly solved Rubix
Cube and then puts it back messed up!
Peter Parker uses Bing?
Dr. Curt Cockings
How and why is he surfing the search results
inside an iFrame on the Bing page?
Oscorp uses Disney ride narration for exposition
purposes.
Peter’s love interest conveniently also
works for the bad guy.
Nonexistent full-color floor-to-ceiling hologram
technology.
Peter bumps into the one shady dude with papers
related to his father’s work.
Peter perfectly mimics a complicated security
touch-screen gesture after watching from 50
feet away.
Floor-to-ceiling holograms, but no security
cameras.
Peter willingly walks into a room with hundreds
of spiders, which no one would ever do.
Spider bite sounds like a cracking whip.
Yehaw.
Skateboard reappears after not having existed
the entire previous sequence.
Peter uses Bing again!
Nonexistent floor-to-ceiling hologram-that-you-can-touch
technology.
More uncle ben lectures about responsibility.
Long-abandoned underground wrestling ring
perfectly positioned to give Peter costume
inspiration.
Wait—is it Christmas time in this movie?
Random microchip in a cell phone equals police
scanner.
Why are all these random citizens gathering
outside the police station?
Peter uses Bing for a third freaking time.
Magic car-door key-code decoder gizmo.
Peter somehow knows exactly which car this
dude is going to steal.
Supporting role given to C. Thomas Howell,
but no Bruce Campbell.
Spiderman takes off his freaking mask.
Police captains don’t issue arrest warrants,
judges do.
This rat lizard puppet is stupid.
Ridiculous pied piper lizard effect.
“Property of peter parker” plot device.
WTF is up with those wounds?
He only got them a few minutes ago.
Peter takes the mask off…
again.
Cell phone reception in the sewers.
Evil villain lair conveniently left unattended
Custom-built presentation software seemingly
created solely to provide crucial plot details.
Exposition by police radio
Use of the phrase Mother Hubbard
Peter’s mask comes off again!!!
Exposition by helicopter pilot.
Turning the cranes should be the new Jumping
the shark.
Bro-bonding eye contact moment.
Spiderman is not a parade.
You do not need to stop traffic for Spiderman.
Canisters of liquid nitrogen should not be
stored on rooftops.
Worst.
Secret.
Identity.
Ever.
Crazy whipping liquid nitrogen tube conveniently
lands right in Spiderman’s hand.
Villain change of heart cliché.
Fatally wounded, but still time for a moral
lesson.
The funeral invitation read: black tie, black
umbrellas only.
These ladders do not begin to provide enough
height or support for a painting of this scale.